Prof: Let us begin,
please.
Today should be a fun day for
us.
We've got some visitors and
it's always --
this particular exercise is one
of the ones that I enjoy most in
this course because we get to
talk with real performers and
find out what's in their head
when they perform a concert for
us.
So our aim today is to continue
along this path to make you,
in this case,
educated critics so that you
can go to a concert of classical
music and you'll be able to
engage it in a productive sort
of way--
in an educated way.
Now there are lots of things we
could think about in terms of
"do's"
and "don't's"
when we evaluate material
musically in a critical fashion,
and we're going to be going
through some of those in section
starting this evening.
And we'll have a big,
long list of,
"this is what you put in a
review and it's probably not so
good to put this in a
review."
But, generally speaking,
when you go to a concert and
you review it--
whether you do it just for
yourself or whether you review
it and then write down your
thoughts and publish them as a
published review--
you do the following.
You're essentially reviewing
the performance.
How well did the performance go?
How did the players do?
You're not engaging who the
composer is.
You're not engaging when the
piece was written,
the history of the piece,
the historical context.
You're not engaging
even--oddly--the meaning of the
piece.
Now on our concert for Saturday
night we have three pieces:
one by Mozart,
one by Brahms and one by
Beethoven.
What's the meaning of the
Mozart, the opening piece?
Well, the meaning there is its
function, in a sense.
It's trying to get the concert
going.
Originally, of course,
it was trying to get the opera
going.
Oddly, the music there in the
overture has nothing to do
specifically with the music in
the opera.
There's no music in the opera
that's also used in the
overture.
But it does have a lot to do
psychologically,
because it's a very intense,
compressed overture and the
opera itself--
if you begin to study that and
the way he's linking scenes and
the way he's moving his harmonic
progressions along--
it's also a very compressed,
intense opera.
So some of the psychological
state of the opera is
encapsulated in that opening
overture, but that overture can
open other things as well.
So there the meaning of the
Mozart,
in essence, is the function of
the piece--
to get people in,
to get them quiet,
to get them focused,
and to give them a heads up,
in a way, as to the
psychological import of the
opera that's to follow.
Now we have also the Beethoven,
the "Pastoral
Symphony"
of Beethoven.
What do you suppose the meaning
of that is?
Pretty straightforward.
Anybody want to take a crack at
it?
Anybody know anything about the
"Pastoral Symphony"
of Beethoven?
What would you guess?
What's it sound like?
Does it sound like a train
wreck?
Does it sound like midtown
Manhattan?
Elizabeth.
Student: The countryside?
Prof: Yeah,
the countryside--a kind of
leisurely embrace of the
countryside--
maybe a walk through the woods
on a beautiful spring day,
that kind of thing.
And each of the
moments--movements--
plays this out in a different
way--sort of an introduction,
then an introduction to the
birds of the forest in the
second movement,
a peasant romp in the third
movement,
a storm gathers in the fourth
movement.
That--we have an extra movement
in this particular symphony
because we've got Beethoven
writing a bit of pictorial music
here in the form of a fourth
movement that's a storm--
and then a hymn of thanksgiving
that plays out in,
basically, a rondo-variation
form there at the end.
So that's the meaning of
that--how an individual might
embrace the countryside.
What's the meaning of the
Brahms?
Well, we've got these
variations and they're simply
sonic patterns.
And we have patterns,
I suppose, in lots of different
art.
Think of abstract patterns in
de Kooning paintings or Jackson
Pollock.
We have a beautiful Jackson
Pollock over in the Yale Art
Gallery.
Well, that's just sort of
abstraction, visual abstraction.
Well, you can have sonic
abstractions as well.
I was talking with our
conductor--whom we'll introduce
in a moment--yesterday about
this.
What's the meaning of the
Brahms--or,
he got to this in a different
sort of way,
and maybe I won't let the cat
out of the bag with that--
but it seems to me that what
we've got here is an
individual--
or an experience in which we
are--we have the same frame of
reference,
the same context,
in other words the theme,
but we're going to engage it in
six or seven really different
ways.
And think of all the times in
your life where you may go in to
the same context.
You may go into your dorm room
and you've had a terrible day
and you're furious and you're
storming around,
or you've had a very pleasant
day or as--
it's been a rather
revenue-neutral day in terms of
your emotional content,
so maybe it's not particularly
moving one way or the other.
You can have the same item that
you engage intellectually or
psychologically in radically
different ways.
So this is the same item played
out in rather radically
different ways musically in this
theme and variation set,
and we'll say more about that
later.
But generally--oddly--you don't
write about these kind of things
when you write a review.
What you're writing about,
again, is how well they played
the piece--
only if they play it in a way
that seems to subvert the
meaning as you perceive it--
the meaning of the piece--is--
does the performance really
impact on the meaning of the
piece then you might say,
"well, this performance
was not successful because,
as I say, it countermanded or
subverted what is the meaning of
this particular piece,"
as you the listener perceive
that to be.
Oddly, also you don't talk
about the form in the pieces.
We've been spending all this
time on form.
Form is a way of getting in
there so we can follow along
intelligently what's happening
in these compositions,
but we don't write a review and
say--
in which we say,
"the orchestra started
out,
and we engaged the first theme
and then we had a fine
transition,
it went to the second theme,
and I really liked that closing
theme;
it had a lot of harmonic bang
to it."
We don't want to sort of be led
by the nose,
if you will,
through the form of the piece,
but we'll be saying a lot more
about this in section--
and, as I say,
we'll have another--yet another
sheet to hand to you.
It helps, when you go to a
concert, to know a little
something about the composer.
Right?
What do you know about
Beethoven?
What do you think of when you
think of Beethoven?
Yes.
Student: The pinnacle of
all music.
Prof: The pinnacle of
Okay, good.
That's an interesting way of
putting it,
and actually even if you look
at this textbook that you're
using there you've got this--
you've got an entire long
chapter devoted just to
Beethoven there.
And when people write history
books, Beethoven is kind of the
lynchpin.
You work up to Beethoven and
then you work away from
Beethoven.
So Beethoven for the nineteenth
century was an icon--was the
pinnacle of what the artist was
supposed to be like.
But it's not just the musical
artist.
Beethoven represented more than
that.
Was he a neat and tidy guy?
Was he sort of uptight guy?
Did he wear a necktie and look
sort of constrained in the
appropriate system of the day?
I'm the ultimate corporate guy,
right?
Was Beethoven the ultimate
corporate guy?
No. What did he look like?
He looked like the prototype of
the genius.
And on the basis of how
Beethoven looked and how
Beethoven acted,
people then began to build this
concept of the genius in the
nineteenth century.
Beethoven was the building
block for this whole idea about
what a genius was--
how he was supposed to behave,
how he was not necessarily to
be held to the same standards as
the rest of humanity in terms of
his behavior to other people.
If necessary to be dishonest,
be dishonest.
He--Beethoven wasn't
necessarily dishonest.
Sometimes Richard Wagner was
but it was excused because he
was a genius.
Well, this sort of idea begins
with Beethoven here in the
nineteenth century.
What did Beethoven write?
Well, as you can see on your
sheet there--everybody pick up
your sheet?
I think I've got--I find it
useful to do this from time to
time,
just sort of the basic
Beethoven, if you will,
and a list of things--if you
want to buy particular pieces or
you want to explore a particular
repertoire of Beethoven,
well, you can do it in this
fashion.
So there is what we need to
know about Beethoven on that
particular sheet.
Brahms we talked about.
We talked about his pieces.
Mozart we will be talking a lot
more about as time goes on.
Now we have--let's turn to our
big sheet here.
What are you going to do with
this big sheet?
Isn't that--you could do a
couple of things with that big
sheet.
An energetic student might want
to go out and go to iTunes and
do what and before the concert?
Student:
>
Prof: Yeah,
get the pieces ahead of time
for ninety-nine cents--except
with the Beethoven.
Why would the Beethoven cost
more?
Student:
>
Prof: Yeah,
you got to pay for each of the
movements.
>
That's the way they sell the
stuff to you,
and, once again,
they'll call them songs.
Right?
Each of--
Student:
>
Prof: I beg your pardon.
And you can go to the music
library because Lynda has been
kind enough to put all of these
on reserve for--all these pieces
on reserve for us also.
So you have this big sheet and
you can take this--you can
engage this material ahead of
time with the pieces.
We don't have any of these
pieces on our CDs.
There are thousands
of--zillions of classical pieces
of music.
We can't put them all on our
CDs.
We have Beethoven's--all of
Beethoven's Fifth Symphony for
example but we don't have the
Sixth Symphony,
but you can get it there on
iTunes if you want to.
And then you can follow along
and ask yourself these questions
as you're listening to a
recording before the concert.
That would be a really serious
type of preparation for this.
Failing that,
you could simply bring this to
the concert,
and then follow along
discreetly as the concert is
going on and ask yourself these
questions and maybe write on it.
It'd probably be good if we
didn't have a hundred people
going like this during the
middle of the concert if we get
on a change of piece or some
change in movement so try to
keep the--
I've seen also students sit
there with computers sort of
taking notes during --
that's a bit over the top it
>
it seems to me.
So it'd be really neat
somehow--what I do…
Actually, what do I do when
this is going on?
'Cause I have to read these
reviews.
Right?
I've got to read them,
so I've got to know,
and the TAs have to know,
what happened.
What I do is I take my program
and I do have a pencil there,
and I take my program and I'll
write little notes on my program
so that I can remember what the
orchestra did at a particular
spot,
and generally speaking the
sooner you write your review
after a performance the better.
So do you have questions about
that?
And we'll be talking more a lot
about that in section starting
again this evening.
Yes, Daniel.
Student: How long
>
Prof: How long do the
reviews be?
Five hundred words--two pages.
A very good question.
We're going to hold you to that.
So they're not long but it
forces you to think about what's
important and what's not
important when you write.
Roger.
Student:
>
Prof: Basically,
you're writing about how well
they perform.
At the end of it,
you could throw in a sentence
or two to the effect that they
met your expectations as to the
meaning of this composition as
the composer intended it or they
did not,
but I would not spend a lot of
time engaging in the review the
meaning of the piece,
no.
So what we'll do--you've got
the five pieces here and we'll
be going over some more of them
in section and getting you up to
speed in terms of the repertoire
as time goes on.
Any other questions before we
introduce our first guest?
Yes.
Student: If we have a
comment to make on the tempo of
the piece--if it's too fast or
too slow, is that our own
interpretation,
is that--
Prof: That's to be
encouraged.
In other words,
if you hear this opening
overture going
>
that's way too slow.
I'm not feeling compressed.
I'm not feeling excited.
I'm not feeling energized by
that tempo.
So you should say there
that--"I think the tempo
was too slow."
Yeah.
It didn't--the music didn't
have energy;
it didn't excite the listener
because the initial tempo was
too slow.
Anything else?
Well, if not,
let's go on to introduce our
first guest and--Bradley Naylor.
Here's Bradley's name up there.
Bradley is the--come on up,
Bradley.
Bradley is the principal
conductor for tomorrow night.
And we will be listening to the
Saybrook Orchestra.
And the rest of our discussion
today is basically between you
and Bradley with me feeding
Bradley questions.
And I'm trying to think about
the kinds of things that you
might want to ask,
but don't hesitate to jump
right-- raise your hand and ask
Bradley a question at any point.
So Bradley, you're a student at
the School of Music.
Right?
Bradley Naylor:
That's right.
Prof: And so tell us
about your musical training.
How did you get started here?
Bradley Naylor:
I sang in choirs.
Gosh, I was probably eight when
I started singing in choirs but
it wasn't until middle school
that I started getting serious.
My middle school music teacher
said, "Hey,
Brad, why don't you try out for
this regional choir thing?"
And I thought well,
okay, I'll submit a tape.
Then I got there and here I was
in this room of twenty-five
fifteen-year-old tenors and they
were all singing the same notes
at the same time and I thought
well,
that's just a miracle.
And so I felt at that point I
had really found what I wanted
to do--
went to high school,
went to undergrad where I
majored in music just down the
road in Providence.
And then I got a master's
degree in choral conducting at
Indiana University out in the
cornfields,
and now I'm back in New England
getting an MMA,
a master of musical arts,
in choral conducting at the
Institute of Sacred Music.
Prof: So your
preparation for this is a little
bit unusual for most conductors
because I think rarely,
or only exceptionally,
do you have people beginning in
music through vocal music that
come around .
Now you're leading an orchestra
here, so doesn't that put you at
something of a disadvantage?
I would think to be an
orchestral conductor it'd be
really good to have started with
the violin or maybe the French
horn so you're listening to
intonation issues and things
like that.
Bradley Naylor:
Yeah.
I would agree with that.
I can't--well,
with the exception of maybe
Robert Shaw,
I can't think of a single
big-name conductor who started
as a choral conductor and now is
in charge of a major symphony
orchestra.
The vast majority of them are
either string players,
keyboard players--a few wind or
brass players here and there--
but I've done a few things to
try and supplement that
perceived lack of knowledge.
When I was an undergrad I took
an orchestration class to try
and get a sense of what the
capabilities and limitations of
all the instruments were.
A couple summers ago I spent a
month at Bard College in New
York at an instrumental
conducting workshop,
where I worked with various
conductors.
So I tried to supplement that
initial choral leaning.
Prof: Uh huh. Uh huh.
But what about piano now?
I'm always surprised how good
pianists these conductors are.
So you must have had to
practice piano,
take piano--
Bradley Naylor:
I do.
I studied piano--I wouldn't say
extensively--but consistently
throughout my young career--
Prof: Because you have
to--
in order to engage the
music--and we'll talk about
this--
you have to be able to do what
with the score?
Bradley Naylor:
I think you have to be able
to play--or realize--the full
score.
Prof: Right,
so it might be the kind of
thing--we would put a score with
maybe twenty lines up there on
the keyboard here and Bradley
would be able to read through
this and digest all these twenty
lines at once,
which doesn't sound all that
difficult,
except a lot of these lines are
not actually written--
the notes that are written
there are not the ones you play
because they're transposing
instruments such as the B-flat
clarinet and the B-flat trumpet
so it's really complicated.
Bradley Naylor:
And in fact in this Brahms
piece there are horn parts in
E-flat, B-flat and C all at the
same time.
Prof: That hurts.
That would be like reading a
text in four languages.
One word is in Cyrillic
alphabet and the next the Latin
alphabet and next Hebrew
alphabet so your mind has got
very quickly to change all--
it's really hard.
It takes years and years of
preparation.
Well, what do you--what's your
goal here?
What do you want to do with
this and where do you want to be
fifteen years from now?
Bradley Naylor:
Oh, gosh.
Well, I don't know if there's a
white picket fence,
but I would like to be teaching
at a university,
directing choruses,
working on choral orchestral
works like maybe Haydn's
Creation or something
like that,
a great piece from the same
period as this Beethoven
symphony.
So--working at a university or
a college level as well as maybe
a professional chorus or
orchestra.
Prof: Okay.
Now here is a question for you.
It might seem like a rude one
but I get--it's my class;
I get to be rude if I want to.
What makes you think you can do
this better than anybody else?
Who says that you get to be the
boss here, the leader here?
Isn't that a bit of hubris on
your part?
Bradley Naylor:
I think that any conductor
has a bit of hubris in him or
her.
I guess the short answer to
that is that whenever I sit in a
rehearsal I'm using my ears--
whenever I sit in a rehearsal
and I'm not conducting I'm using
my ears to try and evaluate
what's coming back,
and I always find myself
forming an opinion.
This could be louder;
this could be softer;
I want to hear that more than I
want to hear this other thing.
So the only place you can
achieve that goal is if you're
in front of the ensemble.
Prof: Yeah.
Oddly, that's what they will be
doing, though,
when they go to this concert.
You guys will be listening and
saying, "Gee,
I--why didn't--I loved that
flute line there.
Why wasn't that flute line
louder?"
So he's kind of a critic,
but he wants to apply his
critical facility here to
interpretation so that's--
to impose his concept of the
music on others for the benefit
of others, I--
Bradley Naylor:
And the next week one of
you can conduct it so--
Prof: Well,
what do they have to have to
conduct?
What's it take to be a good
conductor, do you think?
Just that you've got good
insights in to the music?
Well, I have I think just as
good of insights in to the music
as you do,
Bradley, but I don't think I
would be any good as a conductor
and I kind of know why.
So what do you have to do,
what do you have to have,
to be a good conductor?
Bradley Naylor:
I think it's a varied skill
set.
I think--and don't tell my
colleagues I'm saying this--but
I think at its basis,
the conductor is really just a
glorified traffic cop in certain
ways.
Prof: Traffic cop?
Bradley Naylor:
You have to make sure that
there are no accidents.
You don't want the oboes to
crash into the bassoons;
nobody wants that.
You have to make sure that
people yield when they need to.
If you need to hear the viola
line, you've got to have the
violins yield.
And you just have to make sure
that everyone gets to their
locations without incident and
in as fluid a way as possible.
Prof: Yeah. Okay. Good.
Now here's another component of
this, though.
I've heard of people talking
about it in the terms,
"Well, I have absolute
rhythmic-- sort of an absolute
sense of rhythm.
I can tell what a particular
pulse is.
I can identify that for you,
and I can keep that,
and that's why I'm interested
in becoming a conductor."
Or let's say you're conducting,
and this is where I would
always--
I have done some conducting,
used to conduct the Collegium
here at Yale,
but where I got in trouble was
when something was out of tune I
could hear "Hey,
that doesn't sound good,"
but I couldn't tell 'em why,
or what to do to make it sound
right.
My ear wasn't good enough.
So how good an ear do you have
to be to be a conductor?
How good of an ear do you have
to have?
Bradley Naylor:
I think you have an ear not
just for pitch--
particularly with an
orchestra--but also for timbre,
which is the property that
distinguishes maybe an oboe
sound from a clarinet sound.
Of course, if you're playing a
piano, then <<plays
piano>>
you can't change the timbre of
a single piano note but if
you're playing it on a clarinet
it's going to sound very
different than if you play it on
a trumpet.
So you have to be able to
balance timbres.
And I think before the downbeat
of the first rehearsal a
conductor really has to have the
sound of the piece in his or her
ear,
so I know what needs to be
pulled out.
Maybe the third clarinet is a
little bit sharp so I say,
"Third clarinet,
your B-flat--make sure it
doesn't sit too high."
So I think you have to have the
piece in your head.
There's an old conductor's
mantra: "Always have the
score in your head and not your
head in the score,"
so--
Prof: Well,
okay.
There are all kinds of things I
could ask you about there.
What are you going to do?
Now you're the principal
conductor.
You're doing two of the three
pieces.
You're doing the first half.
You're doing the Mozart and the
Brahms and then Lauren Quigley
will come out.
She couldn't be with us today,
but Lauren Quigley will come
out and lead the Beethoven.
Are you going to try to conduct
any of this without a score and
what advantages and
disadvantage--
sometimes you go to concerts
and a reviewer might notice
that.
Generally speaking,
if you see a conductor
conducting without a score,
what does that indicate?
Bradley Naylor:
Well, I think it's always
impressive to the ensemble when
a conductor is able to conduct
without a score.
Last year Helmuth Rilling,
who is a famous German
conductor,
came and worked with some of
the ensembles and did
Mendelssohn's Elijah,
which is a huge romantic
oratorio about two and a half
hours long.
The dress rehearsal--He came to
the dress rehearsal,
put his score down on the music
stand,
conducted for three hours,
never opened it,
and we were like, "Wow,
this guy knows the score."
So my task is to try to get
four and half minutes of Mozart
in to my head so I don't have to
open that score.
We'll see tomorrow if I am able
to do it--but that's my goal.
Prof: Yeah.
So that sort of talent and sort
of that's a kind of combination
of a photographic memory and a
phonographic memory,
that you've got to--you've got
locked in there.
You can hear something just
once and it's locked in there.
That's the kind of thing Mozart
could do,
and we'll talk more about that
later on,
and--but so your orchestra will
respect you more if you've got
this all memorized.
What does it sort of free you
up to do then obviously if
you've got- if you're conducting
without a score?
Bradley Naylor:
Well, I think at its
essence,
conducting is communicating to
the people in front of you,
and anything that you can get
out of the way between you and
the people who are playing the
music is an advantage.
So I think getting the music
stand out of the way,
getting the score out of the
way, making sure that at all
times you can actually see the
people who are making this
music.
I think anything you can do to
do that is an advantage.
Prof: Yeah. Great.
I want to go back to this
question, though,
of ear because I think it's so
critical.
You were talking about the
third clarinet and "don't
play too sharp."
Well, once again I'd be sitting
there--"who's playing what
that's wrong?"
And I'm wondering are--is it
the oboe maybe--instead of the
clarinet being sharp,
the oboe's flat.
All I hear is a problem.
I don't know what--where the
problem is so--but--and so you
would have to have a pretty keen
sense of pitch.
Do you have what we call
absolute pitch?
Bradley Naylor:
I don't have absolute
pitch.
I have pretty good relative
Prof: Okay.
So I enjoy playing this
particular game with musicians,
and people generally,
where we do an ear training
drill, and I need somebody--is
it Mike?
I just need somebody to come up
and play the piano,
just bang some notes on the
piano.
Who--Daniel,
you know your way around a
keyboard.
You're a guitar player,
so anybody play--the gentleman
here.
Come on up.
Yeah. Okay. Come on up--
Bradley Naylor:
So I'll be where I can't
see the keys--
Prof: Yeah.
So we're going to be over here
and Adam, come play this game
also, and Lynda,
do you want to play this,
down you go in terms of pitch?
Your name is--
Student:  Rahul.
Prof: Rahul.
So--and Jacob,
come on out here also.
Play--start around middle C and
we'll see if anybody can
identify any--and Lynda,
you don't want to play?
I'd like to have some ladies up
here too.
Santana, you come on up and
play the name that pitch game.
And we'll talk about absolute
pitch and we'll talk about
relative pitch.
So play a note and we'll see
how we do.
>
Prof: Oh.
That's up.
Well, can we play a note that's
a little lower?
>
Okay.
Does anyone think they know
what the note is?
But don't--how--anybody up here
think they know what it is?
Student: I would guess
but >
Prof: Bradley,
do you think you know what it
is?
Bradley Naylor:
Yeah, but I have two
guesses and whichever one I say
it's going to be wrong.
I think it's either G or
G-sharp.
Prof: Well,
what do you guys think?
Student: I would've said
A-flat.
Prof: Okay. Okay.
You notice how cagey I am here.
I haven't committed.
Yeah.
That--but just at the outset he
played that initial pitch and
then what did he do?
He dropped it down an octave.
Okay?
So we think that that's--that
probably is an A-flat or a
G-sharp.
Is that correct?
Student: Yeah.
Prof: Okay.
Now knowing that,
play another pitch.
Go ahead, Rob.
>
Anybody know what that is?
So then the question is why is
this guy teaching this course?
>
Right?
Why is he in this profession to
begin with?
Because he's wrestled with this
issue all his life and said,
"Why me?
Why can't I do this?"
and tried to figure it out,
tried to use other tricks to
get around this,
to overcome this handicap and
to hang around with musicians
and sort of explain things that
they do,
that they take in sort of
quickly and intuitively,
and break them down and explain
what it is that they're doing.
So at this point Bradley seems
not to be having trouble with
that pitch.
I don't know what it is --I
could--G.
Yeah. All right. All right.
So I'm out, down I go,
but what was that pitch?
Bradley Naylor: C-sharp.
Prof: C-sharp.
Okay.
All right.
So let's see--now knowing that
that's a C-sharp,
let's see how--let's go--we'll
go a little faster here so we
don't take up too much-- Another
key.
Who knows that?
Bradley?
Jacob?
We should have him write it on
there.
Who doesn't know what it is?
Santana?
Student: Play it again.
>
Prof: Anybody know?
What do you think it is?
Student: G.
Prof: What do you think
it is?
Student: I'll go with G.
Prof: Okay.
>
All right.
So--but what was it? Was it a G?
Okay.
So it seems to me that actually
Bradley seems to be winning
here.
He--this is interesting.
So maybe there is a reason that
he's the conductor here.
The rest--I'm out.
The rest of us are--they're
kind of negotiating with each
other and maybe pegging off of
what Bradley was saying there so
we'll stop this but--
Bradley Naylor:
Well, and maybe I can just
add the--
Prof: Yeah. Okay. Thanks.
Bradley Naylor:
For a person that doesn't
have absolute pitch like myself,
whenever I do hear a note I
think, "Well,
what song does that
start," or is there a chord
or a sonority with which I'm
familiar that I know.
For instance,
so--do you mind if I just do a
little bit of playing?
Prof: Sure.
Bradley Naylor:
So for instance that first
note >
was a G-sharp so I know that
the first aria in Handel's
Messiah <<plays
piano>>
starts with a <<plays
>
G-sharp in the melody and I
kind of know how that sounds
>
and that's how I figured that
was a G-sharp.
The second note he played
>
was a C-sharp or a D-flat.
And there is this great
Fauré piece <<plays
piano>>
that starts <<plays
with this great D-flat so I
kind of find a piece that I can
latch onto.
Prof: That's very
interesting.
In all the years I've been
doing that, I haven't heard that
particular explanation for it.
Most people that have absolute
pitch, "boom,"
they hear it instantaneously.
There is someone in this room
also who has absolute pitch,
but I don't want to go in to
it.
Instances of absolute pitch are
about one in ten thousand,
sort of instantaneous
recognition.
He's getting that but in a
different way.
He must have some kind of
absolute recollection of
particular pieces that are
intentionally impressed on his
oral memory somehow and he then
plays off of those.
That--that's an interesting way
of doing it, but,
as I say, it's not something
that I've encountered before.
Okay.
Well, and so that's kind of
important though.
You got to have a good ear like
that to be able to tell these
people "you're sharp"
or flat.
Now let's say you're in the
middle of things and something
goes wrong.
You have a sense that your--you
know that your clarinet is a
little bit flat.
What--well, you can't just hold
up a sign or an arrow going like
this, can you?
Maybe you can.
How do you get,
in real time--as the piece that
you're conducting and the piece
is unfolding,
how do you get somebody to
correct something in terms of
intonation?
Bradley Naylor:
I think that there is a
difference between what you do
in a rehearsal and what you do
in a performance.
In a rehearsal,
you'd say, "Hold up
there."
The grand pause and say,
"Clarinet there,
fix that."
In a performance,
you hope that you have
inculcated in your performers a
sense of pitch and a sense of
what their function is in a
chord,
so that if something's going
wrong you just look at them and
say,
"Yes, you know you're
wrong.
Fix it,"
'cause you can't stop.
The traffic cop--if you don't
look at the Subaru over here
he's going to crash in to a tree
so you have to take care of
everybody--
but the guy who's running the
stop sign,
you have to take care of that
person first.
Prof: Okay.
So let me ask you this.
Oftentimes you go to a concert,
particularly non-professional
concerts.
At the end of a movement they
will stop and tune.
If we hear in the Beethoven the
tuning between movements,
is that a sign that the
intonation of the previous
movement wasn't all that it
might have been?
Bradley Naylor:
I think it's a bigger
problem with early instruments
that are a little bit more
temperamental,
but certainly if we stop in the
middle and you hear Gabriel
Ellsworth give us a
>
and we retune,
then yes <<plays
piano>>
so that would be--
Prof: He really does
have--
Bradley Naylor:
I was just hearing the
G-sharp from earlier and
it's a half step up.
No problem.
>
Prof: Okay.
So there are some things that
you can do in real time and
things that you just hope that
you've prepared for properly.
But keep an eye on
that--whether they actually tune
between movements.
Now I think we have some other
folks that are going to
demonstrate some things here.
I think we have Katie Dryden,
a viola player or,
the principal.
Okay, Katie,
come on up, and I don't know if
Elana Kagan is here or not.
Is she here--flutist?
Student: I haven't seen
her--
Prof: Oh, my. Oh, my.
Maybe she's sleeping in.
Oh, too bad. We'll say that--
Bradley Naylor:
I doubt it,
knowing her.
Prof: What?
Bradley Naylor:
I don't think she slept in.
>
Prof: I guess it's
only--maybe it's only five
after.
So we do have-- Let's talk
about the Mozart.
We've got this opening piece.
First of all,
which piece of the two
frightens you the most?
You're the conductor.
What are you worried about?
What scares you when you step
out there?
Bradley Naylor: Uh huh.
Well, what's easy about the
Mozart?
Okay. No tempo changes.
Fine, so the whole piece is in
this--in the same tempo.
Problem: If you don't set the
right tempo, you're screwed for
four and a half minutes.
So what I do--
>
I have to get that dead on so
that the whole ensemble knows
exactly what the tempo is.
Prof: Well,
okay.
Then, well, say you mess it up
in the first couple of beats.
Can't you correct it?
Bradley Naylor:
I think a good critic,
as you will all be,
would say, "Well,
this is classical music,
Mr. Naylor,
and there's nothing in the
score that says rit or
accelerando so actually
you should keep whatever tempo
is established at the
beginning."
Prof: Okay. Yeah.
So you're not tempted to get
out there and go "one,
two, one, two,
one two,"
like that.
And I'm always impressed when
conductors they come out and
they kind of look at the
orchestra and they go--
and they just start without
much in the way of preliminary
beats,
but that's kind of risky,
isn't it,
and really dangerous? And--
Bradley Naylor:
But I--one of my conducting
teachers told me,
you know, there's no part in
the score that's labeled
"conductor"
so you shouldn't do anything
other than what's going to get
the people in front of you to
play.
So there's no point in at the
beginning going "One,
two, three, four,"
>
because then you have a
conductor solo for two bars and
it's not in the score so--
Prof: So let's see.
Katie, come on up and do we
have a stand for you?
Did we not--well,
I'm sure we got one inside here
somewhere.
Lynda, maybe our-- Oh, no, no.
Oh, you brought one? Okay.
Well, get your stand out
because we've got the beginning
of the overture to The
Marriage of Figaro here.
Shall we play a CD of it or
maybe we could--let's talk about
Lynda while--I tell you what.
While Katie's getting her stand
let's talk about Lynda.
She's got a bassoon part here.
What happens at the beginning
of this, Bradley,
in terms of the texture:
monophonic, homophonic,
polyphonic?
Bradley Naylor:
It's monophonic.
Prof: Why?
Bradley Naylor:
Because all of the
instrument--there are many
instruments playing but they're
all playing the same line at the
same time.
Prof: Okay.
So--but isn't that a little bit
awkward?
Because some of these
instruments sort of speak a lot
faster than other instruments.
Fast--what would the
fast-speaking instruments,
that could play very
agilely--what would they be?
Bradley Naylor:
I think the violins
probably have the easiest time
of this,
whereas the celli and the
bassoon probably have the
toughest time with this 'cause
it takes lower instruments
longer for them to speak and
make their sounds.
Prof: Uh huh.
So the cellos and basses and
the low part of the woodwinds
that might have a difficult time
here.
So we--Lynda has been good
enough to be a sacrificial lamb
for today and bring in her
bassoon,
and she sent me an e-mail last
night saying,
"Oh, disaster.
I cracked my only good reed and
I'm not going to bring in--I
can't bring in my bassoon;
it just won't work."
So I said, "Come on.
We're really counting on this.
Please bring in your
bassoon."
So here is Lynda with a broken
reed and--hi.
Are you Elana?
Student: Yes, I am.
Prof: Okay.
Come on up.
Good.
So just come on up and take out
your flute and we'll get out the
music here in just a second.
So let's--can we have the
beginning of the Figaro?
Do you want to conduct this or
no?
Bradley Naylor:
Oh, heavens.
This is chamber music at this
point.
Prof: I see. Okay.
Bradley Naylor:
How about I give you a
tempo and then you guys go to
town?
Okay?
I'll give--
Prof: And again I thank
Lynda for doing this because
it's not an ideal situation.
>
Bradley Naylor:
All right.
So here's a safe conservative
tempo, about
>
that fast.
One, two.
>
Yeah.
Cool.
>
Prof: Wonderful. Bravo.
Yeah.
This is great,
the Music 112 orchestra.
Now you said,
"Well, here's a
conservative safe tempo."
Bradley Naylor:
Yeah, that's a safe--
Prof: Well,
what happens if you don't take
a safe tempo?
What kind of disasters might
befall us?
Bradley Naylor:
Well, I think in this case
there wouldn't be a disaster.
It just wouldn't go as fast as
I had set up so I have a
recording of I think it's James
Levine and the Metropolitan
Opera Orchestra--
the highest paid orchestra in
the country--
and they take this at a
blistering tempo,
>
really fast.
Now we'll see how close we can
get.
No. >
Prof: Yeah.
How fast you can take something
sometimes is conditioned by the
acoustical environment that
you're in,
and maybe we'll come back to
that, about the acoustics of
Battell a little bit later on.
Now let's see.
Katie, you're a violist and
you're the principal violist,
and I wanted to ask you--your
job is to kind of ride roughshod
over the rest of the violas here
and how do you do that?
Isn't that like herding
rattlesnakes or something like
that?
Supposing you want to get your
section to be really precise and
really exact and all those bows
going up and down at the same
time,
the articulation exactly the
way they should be.
How do you go--you lead by
example, but in the actual
performance how do you keep
your--the rest of those violas
with you, the principal?
Katie Dryden:
Well, you have to be very
confident about what you are
playing and you can't change
your mind.
So you need to know what--when
you need to come in,
what you need to be playing,
which direction your bow is
moving,
and show that when you're
playing.
It's not by exaggerating,
but just by being confident and
so then the rest of the people
know their parts very well but
will--
and follow off and will have
that little bit of assurance
when you come in.
Prof: Great.
How do you know that they know
their parts really well?
What would you imagine might be
a tipoff?
And you're at a concert and
you're watching,
looking at what's going on.
What would be a tipoff that
maybe they don't know their
parts really well?
They're sitting there with
their nose in the music rather
than watching the conductor.
The more the orchestra is
watching the conductor for the
cues and the interpretation,
the more that says hey,
they've really got this almost
committed to memory and they can
get in--
they can get beyond the notes
into the question of
interpretation there.
Another thing,
and just a very basic thing
that Katie has mentioned here,
is watching--she wants to have
very prominent bow strokes,
I guess, so that everybody--the
whole section--
will be in sync.
If you see this kind of thing
in terms of the bow movement,
maybe the articulation really
isn't all together there.
They should all--each of these
sections should be going in
pretty much the same way.
Is that right?
Bradley Naylor:
Yeah, and particularly with
string instruments there's a
different sound with an up-bow
as--in term--as opposed to a
down-bow.
So an up-bow will start very
small.
A down-bow you can start very
gruffly.
So it does make a difference.
Prof: So Katie,
let me ask you this.
Generally speaking,
violists don't have solos in
the repertoire.
So what's the hardest thing for
you to play there Saturday
night?
What scares you?
Katie Dryden:
What scares me?
Well, like you said,
we don't have solos but we are
very important in that we kind
of hold the upper and the lower
strings and other parts of the
orchestra together.
And I think other sections get
used to hearing us play certain
parts and when we're not there,
they get lost.
That's not only true for
violists.
It's true for pretty much
everyone.
Prof: Yeah.
That's a good point.
You're kind of like the glue
and particularly,
I would imagine,
rhythmically.
I--if you--you might be
setting--really setting the
tempo and these other extremes,
high and low,
are playing off of the rhythmic
tempo that you're setting there
in the middle.
What's the most--is there any
moment that you sort of get to
soar with some music that you
like?
Particularly,
what's your favorite moment,
the most beautiful moment for
you?
Can you play a little of that
moment?
Katie Dryden:
Sure.
In the Beethoven there's a part
in the last movement where we
have the melody,
finally.
It takes a while to get there
but we get there.
>
And that's kind of fun,
that we get to play something
that people recognize.
Prof:
>
Yeah.
Well, I guess it's like maybe
the right guard or a left guard
of a football team.
Nobody ever notices,
but they're actually crucial to
the overall running of this
operation.
Okay.
Now we have also with us--thank
you,
Katie--we also have with us the
principal flutist,
right, Elana Kagan,
and you've got some heavy-duty
exposure particularly in the
Beethoven in the second movement
with all of those solos there.
So here's a question for Katie
with--excuse me--Elana.
With these solos that you have
to play, do you ever get
nervous?
Elana Kagan:
>
Of course.
Definitely.
I mean, when you really have a
solo on your fingers and you
don't have to be nervous,
it makes it even more fun,
and you can always play better
when you're not so focused on
that.
So I certainly try to get
beyond being nervous but
there--it's definitely there and
the trickier it is,
the more nervous I get.
Prof: Well,
what happens to the playing
when you get nervous?
How can we recognize that
you're nervous?
>
Elana Kagan:
Hopefully you can't,
but a lot of times messing up
is a sign of being nervous
because there are a lot of
players who will get it right
every time in rehearsal and then
just the night of the concert
will--
Prof: Yeah, that was me.
I always said I was the world's
greatest warm-up pianist,
>
and then you get to the moment
you have to play and nerves kick
in,
the--just these little
fractions of inches on these
instruments is a question of
life and death.
So if your head isn't all
clear--you can imagine what a
violinist would do if they would
get this huge vibrato--where did
this come from?
>
Okay.
So let's hear if we may,
Elana, some of the lovely,
lovely imitations of bird calls
there in the second movement of
the Beethoven.
What would be good for you to
play?
Choose anything that you like.
So this is Beethoven,
second movement,
theme and variations,
and--
Elana Kagan:
Well, there's one part at
the end that definitely sounds
like--
Prof: Well,
you had the interesting,
I guess, duet with the
clarinet,
that sort of thing,
or--is that what you were
talking about toward the end?
Elana Kagan:
The clarinet and the oboe.
There is a lot of intricacies
between the wind
instruments--having
conversations--so I can play a
couple of those parts.
>
Prof: And then you'll
hear lots of cascading other
woodwinds as Katie--
excuse me--as Elana said with
the oboe and the clarinet sort
of dialoging against this.
Intonation here--do you guys
practice this individually?
Do you have what we would call
"sectionals"
where you get together and work
this out,
or do you only do this with the
full orchestra?
Elana Kagan:
Well, we actually haven't
had sectionals.
That's certainly very common in
orchestras--
to have sectionals to work it
out, but this semester we've
mostly just worked on our own
and as a full orchestra.
Prof: Uh huh.
One of the--one thing--if
instruments are out of tune,
is it--Bradley,
what do you think?
Is it often the woodwinds that
get out of tune?
Bradley Naylor:
I think that--
I don't want to lay blame where
it's not due,
but I think that sometimes it's
easier for instruments that you
can press down a key and know
more or less what the right
support--
what note's going to come out,
but if you have a string
instrument with no frets--
like a guitar has frets on its
fingerboard,
but violins and all the string
family don't--
so that's a little bit more
guesswork so it's really
difficult especially in fast
passage work like Katie was
playing earlier to get a uniform
intonation across the section.
Prof: Uh huh.
So we have really only about
two more minutes left and I'd
like to make the following
point.
One of the things you should be
on the lookout for is balance
over there,
and what the French horns are
doing 'cause this is a really
exposed instrument,
and they're probably going to
be up there on risers and that
sound tends to blare forth in
Battell so keep an eye out for
the French horns.
They'll really be exposed.
I have one other line of
development here but I want to--
before we go,
does anybody out there have a
question that you would like to
ask Bradley or Katie or Elana?
All right.
Let me ask them this question.
Where should we sit?
What are the acoustical issues
involved in Battell?
Do we want to sit so we can see?
And that's not bad.
You might say, "Hey,
well, I'll get way up in
that--as far as I can and watch
this intricate orchestra,
this great, grand machine,
firing on all cylinders
here."
Or do we want to go all the way
to the back and maybe just push
away the visual and just enjoy
the sound?
Because oftentimes in concert
halls the best sound is not up
front;
the sound is sailing right over
your head.
It's coalescing in the back of
the hall.
So where should we sit?
Bradley Naylor:
Well, my favorite place to
sit in concerts is somewhere
where I can see that interaction
between the different,
I guess, gears in the machine,
as you put it.
So I would sit somewhere not
directly behind the conductor,
so somewhere where you can see
the players 'cause they're the
ones actually making the music.
Prof: Yeah.
So if you want to go second
balcony all the way down as far
as you can go,
you can actually get up in
front of the conductor.
You can be--almost be in the
orchestra that way.
Now what about the
acoustics--the last issue
here--the acoustics in Battell?
Are they pretty good, favorable?
Well, it doesn't matter.
Do you have trouble hearing?
Katie Dryden:
Well, they are certainly
different than the room we
practice in,
which is why we have a dress
rehearsal so that we can adjust
our sound according to the
acoustics of the room that we're
playing in.
But I think Battell is a lot
more live, meaning that the
sound sort of--it lives longer
after--
Prof: Yeah.
It's resonant.
It has a very long
reverberation cycle.
How do we cut down?
How can you help the orchestra?
What would you guess?
What would be the best way you
could help the orchestra to
bring clarity to their sound and
actually allow them to play
faster,
get that tempo of the Mozart to
go faster?
If you've got a long
reverberation cycle in a hall,
your tempo will go slower.
What can you do to help out
here?
Nadav, what do you think?
What would you do?
Student: Wear a sweater.
Prof: Wear a sweater.
Bring a teddy bear.
Bring your friend.
Bring your mother, grandmother.
Bring as many people.
Get as many sound-absorbing
bodies in there as you possibly
can.
So we'll see you then Saturday
night, eight o'clock,
and thanks to our guests.
>